à présent une activité de 8 sur self
vous avez déjà découvert des recettes de
lessive ou de dentifrice cette semaine
c'est au tour du produit pour les lave
vaisselle on voit ça avec mélanie poker
bonjour c'est une recette très rapide où
il faut compter au moins une dizaine une
petite dizaine de minutes pour réaliser
une quarantaine de passer alors on va
bien sûr de débuter avec les ingrédients
vous aurez donc besoin de 200 g de
cristaux de soude 250 g de percarbonate
de 200 grammes d'acide citrique et 100 g
de growth elle est bien sûr un petit peu
d'eau lors au niveau des ustensiles un
saladier une cuillère et un bouchon en
liège catherine thomas de l'association
vérité nous explique les propriétés des
ingrédients le percarbonate 6-1 blanche
qui sans un détachement et un purifiant
et un désodorisant les cristaux de soude
c'est un nettoyant et un dégraissant et
l'acide citrique c'est un détartrant est
un anti calcaire assez puissant le sel
enlève les bactéries également vous
pouvez commencer à mettre les 4 premiers
ingrédients dans le saladier et bien sûr
vous mélangez le tout et il accepte
aussi s'arrêter là alors on peut en
effet s'arrêter là on met directement le
mélange dans un pot ça sera de la poudre
tout simple il faut juste un pur bien
étanche pour que ça ne durcissent pas
alors si vous êtes vous optez pour des
pastilles on écoute à nouveau catherine
thomas vous allez prendre votre pape aux
rédacteurs dos et vous allez vaporiser
délicatement à peu près je mets à peu
près 5 pression mais je commence déjà
une première un premier jet et ça fait
tout de suite une réaction voit que ça
commence à mousser vous mélangez le tout
il faut surtout surtout éviter de ne pas
trop mettre d'office que vos pastilles m
ont gonflé
ça sera pas ça trappe à l'effet souhaité
qu'à partir du moment où ça fait un peu
comme un crumble
vous pouvez les mettre en bacs dans
votre bac à glaçons alors une fois cette
étape terminée vous mettez comme l'a dit
catherine thomas le produit dans le bac
à glaçons vous éviter de toucher avec
les mains car les produits peuvent être
irritants il faut sud compact et vos
pastilles et qu'un bouchon de liège une
nuit de séchage dans un endroit sec et
le tour est joué vous obtenez des
pastilles a glissé dans le comportement
de votre lave vaisselle merci mélanie
pour cette recette de 8 sur 16